[Applaudissements]
il a quel âge maintenant il va sur ses
sept mois à ces essais le vous donner le
biberon ah oui oui je participe je
change tout en céréalière j'ai amené
chez le médecin puis il avait un petit
peu un petit rhume away et pour la vie
tu m'as fait caca dans les mains non
alors ces signes de fertilité
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comment s'est passé l'enregistrement
questions pour un champion en poche
tient en fait c'est très frustrant parce
que jenson l'usaid bosi n'ont pas aidé
beau le client n'a pas redonné - la
guinée rotenberg est dégonflé parce que
prince fois qu'on s'est croisé europe 1
je t'ai demandé c'était marié et puis tu
m'as sinon ouais ça pousse
[Applaudissements]
attendez la bande fm il s'est marié
oui je suis un jeune héros on la voit ça
de moi c'est six mois en mois sur une
jeune mariée ne sais pas mais je suis
marié frérot si jamais vous fait plus de
deux millions aujourd'hui
oui vous montez dans votre voyage là à
las vegas aux puristes fait plus de deux
millions aujourd'hui
alors je sais que vous n'êtes pas loin
mais on n'est pas loin millions
d'actions de 15 hier voilà et bien non
très bien sûr si vous avez de deux un
chèque à faire
ça disait s'embrasser et je vous dira
l'enfant l'enfant et de moi
[Applaudissements]